15 years gentlemen what is where is your
where are your heads right now when it
comes to your your family of crew your
family of casts that you built over the
year and the fandom mm that's been next
to us and supported you guys supported
me supported all of us for 15 years
where your head's at honestly I don't
mean your heads like the show's going
and sad like yeah internally your lives
will change now mmm
way that they've been different for the
first time in 15 years to be fair this
changed our lives
yeah and and our lives will have have
not and will never be the same
mmm kind of my mental state right now is
pretty much the same as it generally is
with the beginning of the season which
is starting out of a marathon Beckham I
got to pace myself and I got to get the
work done and you know we were talking
about this earlier this it's like
because it is the last season yeah I
know that on the outside but for me I'm
kind of trying to block the whatever
emotional rabbit hole that might take me
down and just stay focused on doing the
best job that I can do what I continue
to do that whatever that the job that
it's got me here after 14 years and and
I'll let all that emotional and let all
that rabbit hole find me
come holidays later yeah for me it's
hard to think about right now watching
you guys man I yeah I feel like somebody
asked me question one time like what's
gonna be like to say bye to Sam
Winchester
and my honest answer was like I'm I
can't say bye to them like he's gonna be
a part of me forever and I met some of
my dear friends that will continue to
see each other all the time and you know
so as far as the show ending I don't
know yet I don't know if that's like a
protective defensive mechanism that like
I certainly get all teary like comic-con
was a weird experience so he goes up
there difficult that was really
difficult and then it's sort of like and
you know I mean we known each other
well over ten years it's sort of like
okay got it mmm all right back up walk
let's go like so right now it's sort of
like that all right back on the clock
you know game on you know it's like game
off
car's gone game on all right all right
so I don't know ask me in April again do
the as you guys have I know you're just
finishing - are you still in - right
we're halfway through or the second
episode fiance of shooting you know did
the first one you directed the first one
that got shot this season rekt did it
feel for you as a director actor he was
an actor when you got to the end of it
did it feel like that was the last time
of the first like the last time like I
know me should joke that it's the last
of everything yeah but does it feel like
inside like that's gonna be the last
time I feel what it is to come back
after hiatus and crack it open again and
yeah yeah I I had a bit of that first
day kind of walking back on set seeing
all those familiar faces smelling those
familiar smells walking into my trailer
walking onto the soundstage walking up
to the production office seeing
everybody that you know and it's it's
it's kind of back to work but there was
that kind of underlying feeling of this
is this is the last time that this is
gonna happen yeah and it's uh it's it's
a it's a weighty feeling I mean you
think about how long we've been doing
this and it's like you know when we come
back usually we come back there's
there's just like okay it's just back
back to business it's business as usual
which we'll be doing this again next
year we'll be doing this again in the
year after that and it's been like that
for a long long time so to come back and
know that this is the final first day
it's so weird for me as an outsider semi
inside but like I've known you guys and
I've watched you guys and now cuz I get
to the blessing of directing you fellows
wait man can't wait hey little director
right here we got a little something for
you don't you worry no worries you are
in deep no I'm gonna lighten it up a
little bit is there I talked to me about
the cars he says there's people want the
cars I get that of course sure who
doesn't want that Impala
have you liberated anything else I'm
sure you have I almost don't even want
to look at you guys when I ask this
question
souvenirs things that have met there's
so many cool props from this show yeah
cool wardrobe do you have plans on
liberating a thing that you must have to
take home from whether it be first
season of the 15th season or what I have
a few things that I've had gone that
there are a few things do you work for
Warner Bros there are a few things I've
gone missing no but she does earmuffs I
I take my my chair back every year and I
think this one's gonna be a pretty
special one to take you know which makes
production means the production is to
buy him a new one every year it's like
40 bucks I'll write a check if you need
so yeah I like I take my chair backs you
know I have like little knickknacks from
sets we're gonna burn down like when
Bobby singers house burned down I
grabbed like a little owl you know
bookend and it's like a just random
flask from a scene yeah the subject
Department is gonna go through a few of
these sets and look around and be like
where did everything go
yeah yeah I I it you know without
without getting in specific specifics
and and and you know there are certainly
little things that that have an
emotional that we have emotional ties to
you know of whether it's whether it's a
clock that's been sitting on a desk for
so long whether it's a lamp whether it's
a you know a vinyl record that's been
sitting on the top of Dean's vinyl stack
in his room for so long I might just
take our props girl Maisy I don't know I
really like stage two it's always been
my favorite that's a little bit bigger
so in the back of the truck no I mean
you need a flatbed right yeah a little
bit bigger so ring it apart you've been
there yeah
origami it's a tilt up construction you
got it nowhere they won't even notice
it's gone which is a great thing
thinking back to this is I'm sure you
guys have been asked to think back on
the season so often but I'm gonna take
this moment for myself thinking back to
the episodes I've done with you guys
yeah
very few we've done
three episodes the last one we remember
obviously we sat in a car and you know
for a million pages and then it was over
but I feel like we've done that 30
episodes I know because we see each
other so are you I've never even acted
in a scene with me should we just
discovered in the last series look we've
never ever been in a scene on
supernatural together we've created many
of scenes
Missy you know it's so much chemistry
though what what do you remember
anything from working with me either one
of you by any chance I knew I felt you
know when I first came on as John and
then there was the Michael bit yeah we
were in the house and all that stuff
later I'm gonna be really honest the
first time we ever met was in we call it
the the fishbowl and we were reading the
script
and I think and you you're a ripped guy
and you're coming in we were doing the
script reading with everybody from down
south and I you had shaved arms I mean
if you still shave your arms yeah we
finished reading the script and I was
like dude because she is armed he must
be a douchebag
yeah honest to god first of do you want
to know something I remember a Jensen at
one of the first times we were at a
convention together this was early on
she was really after into the episode
and he came up to me anyway hey don't
want to see these things
Oh Harry next time I see you alright not
a word of a lie we walked out I was like
a little bit back on the show listen
armband get an armband and I was like
listen he's jacked he don't need to wear
arm man and shave his arms to listen oh
he's jacked like a ribbon arm band on I
think you did you had it yeah like a
like a wristband a source listen wheel
you weren't working out either we all
make mistakes and then as we go like you
were doing bar dips so there was a
45-pound plate no and then as we obvious
get to know each other it was a real joy
for me before it's kind of come full
circle and do the scene where you're Jon
Lester again and we're because now I
know you as a father as a man as a
husband as a friend after 12 years 13
you however long an event yeah and
there's some great and you know the
feeling as well like when you try
who you're across from whoever it is
whatever the situation whether it's
acting in a scene or if you're a doctor
and you trust your whatever it is yeah
vice versa so it was really cool to play
in that scene and to know like you were
gonna push me because you knew me and
you knew what I was capable of and vice
versa I was gonna push you because I
know you and I know you're capable of so
that was a funny full circle from like
he's wearing armband and shaves his arms
I don't like him I'm still the same
Cohen exactly to finish up what a
message to the fans and I don't mean a
message thank you fans give them a way
to cope tell tell hmm I know you guys
are gonna crush this season I know the
the product that you turn out it's been
great since season one which I just
binge watched for the first time and I
have to applaud you guys really bringing
it from the pilot and I'm not saying
that as my like I'm saying that as a guy
who's sure dissecting his directing
skills and watching what you guys did
from day one beautiful what can you tell
the fans what's what what can you say to
help them deal with not having this in
their life every day yeah well I mean
this is the great thing about on demand
is they can't have it go back and just
watch their favorite seasons I will say
that you know we we obviously made this
decision with with very heavy hearts and
and and it was wasn't a difficult time
it wasn't a difficult thing to to come
to the realization of it was difficult
yes it was very hard and it will be hard
and but at the same time I feel like we
never wanted to stick around if the
product started to wane or if we weren't
able to bring it every day if if if the
car started to run out of gas we didn't
want to be we wanted to get out before
that already was so going and not to say
that it is and not to say that that we
are running out of gas not to say that
we're you know we're tired of it but I
think we've gotten to a point where
where we feel really really solid about
where we are but we feel like we still
have tons of energy and tons of passion
and tons of love enough for the show to
go out with a bang and I think that I
would rather hang my hat on that than to
hang my hat on some kind of like fear
now sure yeah this is a we wanted to go
out while the party was at its peak you
know we wanted to leave the party we
want didn't want to be the last people
going like whoa who can fill my drink
okay
you're welcome to legal Oh got it that
happens enough to Jared in real life yes
yes on a daily twice a day basis you
know the show could go for the show
could go for many more years and still
be a great show but we want to go out
leaving not only the the fans wanted
more but also us wanting more like I
hope this isn't the last time I have
played Sam Winchester yeah and also
going back to kinda what I touched on
earlier like when people say how's it
gonna be to say by the supernatural or
by the Sam Winchester I'm never going to
say bye like it'll always be a part of
me and hopefully for the fandom that's
spent three or twenty seven hours
watching or three or in seven episodes
it'll always be a part of them whether
it's tangible or intangible but some
part of them some part of what made them
feel the way they feel or think the way
they think so for me that's kind of
where I I say and hopefully I'm not
saying farewell hopefully I'm saying see
you later yeah but this show whether it
goes 20 more years or ends this season
will always be a part of it
[Music]
you